sono qui per raccontarvi un esperimento
che ho iniziato a fare circa cinque anni
fa mi sono seduto al computer e ho
scritto una mail indirizzata a tutti i
miei contatti nella quale in sostanza
che devo loro di fare tre cose la prima
di smettere di fare quello che stavano
facendo la seconda di guardarsi intorno
la terza di scegliere un oggetto ma
l'oggetto doveva essere scelto secondo
il principio della parità cioè la scelta
doveva ricadere su qualche cosa che non
suscitasse sentimenti di superiorità o
di inferiorità
al contrario qualcosa di percepito come
vicino cordiale amico
insomma un oggetto alla pari per
spiegarmi personalmente non potrei
scegliere alla pari un vocabolario di
latino perché non mi esprimo e latino
non usa latino pur avendolo studiato ma
posso scegliere con una certa
spontaneità e sentirmi a mio agio e
quindi alla pari con una caffettiera
cioè io con una mucca del caffè possa
addirittura pensare di parlare poi la
mail continuava chiedendo alle persone
di venire nel mio studio con l'oggetto
scelto e di raccontarmi i motivi che
avevano portato a questa scelta
nel frattempo io avrei fatto delle foto
e bene hanno risposto all'invito 24
persone che più è venuto più convinto
chi titubante che curioso ognuno col
proprio oggetto per esempio alberto
alberto ha scelto una molletta del
bucato in questa immagine sta parlando
del rispetto di sé oppure gabriella che
è un'appassionata di macchine sportive
sceglie un modellino di macchina la
sfida è in questa immagine sta parlando
del piacere della lentezza o ancora
andrea
che si sta domandando cosa ci sta
facendo qui con una melanzana però è
l'oggetto giusto loris invece sceglie un
megafono costruito a mano lo guarda lo
osserva e in questa immagine sta
ascoltando la sua voce profonda oppure
chiara che avventa la vita e con la sua
scarpa parla di amore e di famiglia
allora cominciamo a vedere che quello
che io avevo immaginato dava i suoi
frutti e cioè che un oggetto per il
fatto di essere scelto restituisce
qualcosa di colui o colei che ha operato
la scelta e quindi la scelta diventa un
atto comunicante però non era
sufficiente perché le persone in
questione mi conoscevano già quindi
c'era un rapporto
allora ho riscritto tutto sotto forma di
progetto d'arte loro chiamato discorso
alla pari e lo ha presentato in altri
contesti sociali come il mondo delle
imprese all università o il teatro qui
avete il risultato ottenuto in alcune
aziende
ho incontrato un centinaio di persone
che svolgevano mansioni diverse dal
fattorino all'impiegato l'operaio
l'amministratore delegato e qui mi sono
convinta della bontà dell'idea ma per
entrare più nel dettaglio e spiegarvi
che cosa scatena quale dinamica si attua
nel momento in cui scegliamo un oggetto
percepito alla pari
vi racconto di questo ragazzo dunque mi
trovo in una tipografia e il suo
mestiere è quello dello stampatore
infatti porta un utensile per lui cioè
le spatole per stendere l'inchiostro
nella stampa tipografica i colori sono
quattro ciano magenta giallo e nero e
dello stesso colore sono le spatole
dunque ritrovo in fabbrica c'è un'area
dedicata al progetto
sto aspettando il prossimo oggetto
lui entra con aria molto distante e
subito dal dunque mi dice sappi che io
non ho letto molti libri però sono una
cosa che tu non sai
so di che colore è l'alba perché la vedo
tutte le mattine mi alzo molto presto
per venire al lavoro e vedo che l'alba
non è mai uguale anche fosse per una
piccola sfumatura è sempre diversa anche
io ho diverse sfumature e usa la
comincia a usare le spatole al rosso che
la parte di me che trattengo la rabbia
quella che non esprime ma allo stesso
tempo al giallo arancio che la parte di
me più cordiale quella che sta bene con
gli altri
poi al blu che è la parte più riflessiva
quella anche un po più melanconica
quella che pensa però e poi o il nero
che la parte di me che mi fa paura
quella in ombra ecco vedi mettere
insieme tutte queste sfumature per me
non è facile e fa un discorso alla pari
sul carattere allora vedete come nel
momento la scelta è importante dal
momento in cui il mio sentimento si
dirige verso un oggetto fino a quando
scelgo e decido che è quello giusto e
poi di conseguenza agisco ne parlo lo
motivo faccio le foto ecco tutto insieme
questo
restituisce uno straordinario
autoritratto in altri termini nella
misura in cui noi scegliamo in accordo
con la nostra parte più profonda nel
rispetto della nostra indole riusciamo a
far emergere la parte di noi più bella
più efficace perché ho fatto tutto
questo perché circa cinque anni fa mi
sono trovata a prendere una decisione
per me molto delicata se abbandonare la
mia professione artistica per ragioni
economiche
avevo perso i miei contratti più
importanti ed ero rimasta senza lavoro
oppure persistere nonostante le
previsioni più nere e finché stavo
pensando queste cose con lo sguardo
perso in un orizzonte che non vedevo
avevo un fiore tra le mani è il fiore ha
cominciato a parlarmi e questo vi dà
l'idea dello stato d'animo parlavo coi
fiori o persa ma il fiore mi ha risposto
materialmente e mi ha detto una cosa
interessante cioè io sono una gerbera
sono rossa vado bene così mi piaccio
o forse dovrei essere un tulipano ho
dato ascolto al fiore ho deciso di
seguire la mia indole ho deciso di
persistere e questo mi ha dato la forza
per risalire la china e come potete
immaginare ha anche ispirato il progetto
di cui vi sto parlando che è diventato
nel tempo parte del mio lavoro
quindi confermo quello che ho intuito
all'inizio e cioè che scegliere in
accordo con la propria profonda natura
non fa che far emergere la parte di noi
veramente più attiva più vincente
addirittura e vi invito a farlo provate
ad esso più tardi domani
pensate un oggetto
sceglietelo ascoltatelo domandatevi
perché l'avete scelto ciò che conta è
però che la scelta sia fatta
completamente alla pari
grazie